[Music]
once in a while a little voice will pop
in my head and say Dave are you sure you
aren't over blowing any of the big
issues that you talk about maybe the
threat to free speech really isn't so
bad
maybe the assault on open discourse on
college campuses isn't all that terrible
maybe most of the mainstream media isn't
simply pandering for clicks and views
then and it never fails some current
event takes place reminding me that the
issues that we're talking about related
to free speech are not only the most
important issues of the day but perhaps
were actually under estimating the
severity of them without an absolute
protection of free speech first we can't
have debates around any of the other
issues that might be important to you
right now care about Betsy DeVos is
comments on title 9 care about Trump's
decision on daca or global warming as it
relates to the recent spate of
hurricanes your freedom of speech and of
inquiry is what guarantees that we can
have discussions around those issues and
everything else tomorrow former Rubin
Report guests and a friend of mine Ben
Shapiro will be speaking at UC Berkeley
the Internet has been lit about the
pre-emptive protests the counter protest
the safe spaces and the trigger warnings
for this event even before the events
has actually happened sadly in and of
itself none of this impending and hyped
up chaos is new so I wasn't planning on
addressing it before Ben even had the
chance to speak then I saw a tweet from
the Los Angeles Times and I felt I
needed to discuss it with you the tweet
reads quote Berkeley braces for
right-wing talk-show host Ben Shapiro
visit end quote
now this headline doesn't seem too bad
on face value actually it reads very
similarly to how much of the mainstream
news is published these days if you're
looking for it though and I know many of
you are the headline is actually a
loaded combination of subtle bias and
outright fake news Berkeley braces is an
interesting choice of words because
usually in headlines we brace ourselves
for a hurricane or another natural
disaster the attempt here of course is
to compare Shapiro's words with the same
emotional weight as a natural disaster
which can actually
and lives in a time right after two
major storms hurricane Harvey and
hurricane Irma hit the United States
this phrasing is particularly useful as
we are all subconsciously associating
the word brace with death and
destruction if you think I'm overstating
the word brace with hurricanes just do a
Google News search for braces for Harvey
or braces for ArmA and see what pops up
now the Los Angeles Times reader knows
that something so horrible is coming
that UC Berkeley must brace for it as it
would for a deadly hurricane next they
use the pejorative right wing to opine
on Ben's talk-show and his views of
course there's no doubt that as a
conservative Ben's political views are
on the right but there's something else
when they say right-wing virtually every
time the mainstream media uses the
phrase right wing it's to paint someone
as either scary evil or as a racist in
and of itself being right-wing isn't bad
it's just a political view one which you
may or may not agree with but here we
now have students bracing for this right
wing speaker sounds scary doesn't it why
does the mainstream media never label
anyone or anything left-wing when they
want to scare you has an Tifa been
labeled left-wing by the LA Times or CNN
I searched the LA Times calm for those
words together and unsurprisingly it has
not while right-wing is a dog whistle
for bad and left-wing is just left out
altogether when it doesn't fit the
correct narrative you really have a
problem did you see a headline in the LA
Times or CNN that read City University
of New York braces for left-wing
activist Linda Sarsour of course you
didn't and I would argue that Linda's
our sewers ideas are far more dangerous
than anything that ben shapiro talks
about if you think I'm being a bit
melodramatic here consider this as long
as the LA Times is using colorful
language with their headlines why didn't
they add a fun adjective before UC
Berkeley
I mean Berkeley was once the home for
free speech in America and it is now
ACEF
left-wing see I can do it to hate why
not say former school of academic
freedom Berkeley
is for right-wing talk-show host Ben
Shapiro or intolerant of other ideas
Berkeley braces for right-wing talk-show
host Ben Shapiro or even simply and most
honestly and directly if we're being
fair to both sides
left-wing Berkeley braces for right-wing
talk-show host Ben Shapiro certainly
that would be true at least but their
omission of one label while prescribing
another one tells you all you need to
know this headline before Ben has even
spoken tells you a story all right but
it isn't the one that the LA Times
intended the headline tells you the
story of the double standard with which
mainstream conservatives have to deal
with fueled by a media that inflames the
situation when it comes to anyone on the
right but largely ignores it when it
comes to anyone on the left this tricky
use of words and selective writing is
largely what people are talking about
when they talk about fake news the media
should be giving us facts straight up
not editorializing through headlines
that confuse and conflate what's
actually happening on the ground if
you'd like to know more on how the media
confuses us with headlines like this
check out my discussion with Eric
Weinstein on the rustle conjugation and
we'll link to that video right down
below Ben is going to speak at UC
Berkeley and he is going to say some
things that'll trigger some people not
because he's attacking individual people
or because the things that he's saying
are inherently offensive but more so
because he's challenging the social
justice warrior ideology that is
ransacked clear thinking on the college
campus in America if you don't like what
he says write a paper about it invite a
counter speaker or non violently protest
in a way which allows the people who do
want to hear him have a chance to
exercise their right to free speech just
as much as you want to exercise yours
headlines like this subtly excused and
actually helped instigate violence
toward anyone who dares step out of
groupthink I guarantee that the ideas
that Ben talks about tomorrow are in no
way something you have to brace for and
even less something that you have to act
violently towards defending free speech
as a college student now will help
ensure that it will be defended when you
grow out of the groupthink as an adult
so instead of sign
speakers on campus perhaps do what
you're supposed to do in college instead
listen to someone who thinks differently
than you do this way you will learn how
to think and instead of having to brace
yourself for bad ideas you can arm
yourself with good ones
[Music]
you